we're outside this one they're not
planning on taking this alive so they
come with us you're a wanted man what
else suit up
cavitus dangerous
you're toast alongside keep telling
yourself that this is gonna
hey youtubers is Charlie so a bunch of
Captain America stuff happening they've
been shading each other on their press
tour so I'm gonna play a couple of funny
videos of them just going back and forth
real quick like a weight vest yeah
that's exactly why I only do vegan
plant-based protein me and that's good
it's just a vegan
oh I wouldn't see that we were just
talking about trying to stay in shape
you know unlike certain superheroes who
wear suits to do all the work for them
we actually get out there and you know
push-ups squats and those without men
alone we sweat you know come to think of
it have we ever seen Tony Stark do a
single pushup no I've never seen all set
what do you say Robert Downey jr.
push-up contest hmm tell you what what
do we spot 21 spots each one two dubs
homey get in hi team cap thank you so
much for your invitation to the team
Ironman to take part in the push-up
competition sounds very grown-up um I
thought before accepting it would be
interesting to look up the word meathead
in the Oxford English Dictionary
oh it says C Chris Evans or Anthony
Mackie uh well it's very brief on the
subject it says a stupid person and then
it gives a helpful little example of how
to use it in a sentence it says shutup
meathead and as you're told
we'll see you at London the whole idea
with the first clip is just in trowing
ant-man to the team there's a bunch of
really spoilery stuff that people have
been talking about him doing in the
movie without spelling it out completely
yes it's all totally happening we even
know who he's gonna be fighting on team
Iron Man it's gonna be amazing
your brain will melt but I love the way
team cap is shading team Iron Man just
by saying they're a bunch of dandies
bunch of old men in suits and then Paul
Bettany the vision fires back just
calling them a bunch of meatheads it's
totally great some of the jokes have
been funnier than others is there any
like really funny ones I'll do more
videos for him but this is just them
doing different types of promos for the
movies instead of like the straight-up
trailers like the clip at the beginning
of this I'm always really
fascinated with the way movies and TV
shows market themselves everybody tries
something a little bit different every
year so because this is team cap versus
team Iron Man they're just having some
fun with that if Chris Evans and Robert
Downey jr. ever actually did get into a
fight he would squish our DJ like a
grape the funny thing about Chris Evans
is that when they first started phase
one when they were doing the first
Captain America film when they were
doing the first Thor film Chris
Hemsworth had already bolt up so he was
already you know big huge Thor looking
guy but Chris Evans hadn't quite got
there yet so everyone always jokes about
how he was asking Hemsworth for tips
about bodybuilding like how do you get
your arms so big like you know how do
you get that muscle on the back of your
arm do you know like how do you get all
this crazy definition and now you look
at Chris Evans and he's probably even
bigger than Chris Hemsworth Chris
Hemsworth is still really tall I think
Chris Evans is actually the stronger guy
and I know a lot of you guys have been
asking about the Inhumans movie it's not
directly related to Captain America
stuff but I will say that they've taken
it off the schedule there are a lot of
rumors that it wasn't Kevin Feige idea
to do a Marvel Inhumans movie it was his
old boss Ike Perlmutter's idea he wanted
to use it as ammunition against Fox's
x-men franchise because visually an
Inhumans movie would look a lot like an
x-men film so it'd be like big
competition for them so when Kevin Feige
was allowed to take Marvel Studios and
go off on their own like often to their
own special little territory and just do
their own thing the rumor is that the
Inhumans movie just got dropped from the
schedule because they were like well we
didn't want to do this in the first
place we were forced to put an Inhumans
movie on our schedule now that that's
not an issue we're not even gonna worry
about it you could also speculate this
is just a theory that they're taking it
off the schedule because they don't want
to compete with x-men they want to find
a way to work with x-men so they can
share characters infox would probably be
much more willing to do that if Marvel
didn't develop a movie in direct
opposition to their x-men franchise
because it took them years to work out
the Sony deal with spider-man and
sharing that character I think an x-men
Marvel crossover is still years and
years away
maybe after infinity or some time but I
totally think eventually we will see
Wolverine with the Avengers let me know
in the comments though what do you think
about these funny promos they've been
dropping for Civil War do you like them
better than you like the actual trailers
and do you think that Marvel is going to
cancel Inhumans indefinitely and they'll
just look like Black Bolt and the other
care
actors go to the TV show it would make
sense from a business standpoint because
Marvel doesn't really need the Inhumans
money that it would make from that movie
they've already got more than enough
movies for single-phase probably too
many so it's not like they're running
out of ideas and they just need to start
scraping the bin for Inhumans and other
minor characters it remains to be seen
if I hear any other rumors I'll totally
do a video for it but right now it's a
relatively minor thing big stuff
tomorrow is Game of Thrones so be sure
to subscribe to get all those videos
I've got a new flash season 2 video I'm
working on because we learned all about
Kevin Smith's episode and there's the
trailer for next week's episode so
that'll actually probably be what my
next video is but that probably won't
post til Sunday morning I will be
posting updates through the day tomorrow
my Facebook page is just called
emergency awesome real simple my twitter
page is twitter.com slash awesome
emergency so it's just a little bit
different tomorrow is gonna be a lot of
fun I cannot wait to watch everybody get
catfished by a very certain Game of
Thrones character it's gonna be the
funniest thing ever so while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for all my other Civil War
videos and you can click here to get
ready for Game of Thrones season 6 I
just did like a big guide video for
everything you need to know thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you